[Music]
wondering when the US will swoop in to
defeat Isis you're not alone in the last
two weeks Isis has captured the city of
Ramadi and Iraq and the ancient Syrian
city of Palmyra those are major
victories for the group and a painful
blow to the us-led coalition that's
trying to destroy it the Iraqi forces
were attacked by suicide bombers as they
moved into Isis terrain to take back
ramadi this week but the loss of the
city has a lot of people in Washington
rethinking America's role in Iraq so
what is the u.s. strategy in the fight
against Isis well it wasn't too long ago
Obama said this our objective is clear
we will degrade and ultimately destroy
ISIL through a comprehensive and
sustained counterterrorism strategy
since then his strategy is primarily
relied on leading coalition airstrikes
but has also included restructuring the
Iraqi government and deploying at least
3000 military advisers but that hasn't
been enough and since the fall of an
ahmadi iraq and the u.s. have been
pointing fingers over who's to blame for
the failure to contain Isis US Secretary
of Defense Ashton Carter sorted through
the Iraqis under the bus what apparently
happened was that the Iraqi forces just
showed no will to fight they were not
outnumbered I fact they vastly
outnumbered the opposing force but is
putting all of the blame on the Iraqi
government fair not according to some
analysts and officials on the ground
they say the u.s. effort has failed
largely because of Washington's focus on
airstrikes rather than providing the
weapons and training that the Iraqi
security forces need to actually take
out Isis something that was proven in
Ramadi here's what Al Jazeera's Imran
Khan reporting from Baghdad told me
about the Iraqi forces well they've been
training now in 18 a year and the train
has gone well but has it been effective
I mean take a look at the Iraqi security
forces when it came to Ramadi they
simply disappear the Iraqi army
disappeared these were us training
soldiers you have to ask yourself is the
training working maybe not when you
consider the fact that Isis is stronger
than ever hundreds of thousands of
Iraqis have been displaced and Isis
continues it's slow push towards Baghdad
but training isn't the only problem of
the u.s. strategy the plan does little
to bring Iraq sex ethnic groups and
their backers to agree on a solution
each side is suspicious of the US and
that hasn't helped in establishing a
coherent strategy you could credit the
2003 US invasion of Iraq for that the
u.s. toppled saddam hussein's regime and
dismantled the iraqi army thousands of
Iraqis Sunnis lost their military jobs
and took their experience to join armed
groups hell-bent on destabilizing things
sectarian tensions went through the roof
thanks in large part of the divisive
policies of the Iraqi government's that
followed all that laid the foundation
for Isis today add the turmoil in Syria
to the mix and you've got one hell of a
confusing situation for the u.s. to try
to solve the situation right now is very
very simple without a political solution
in Syria you are not going to get a
solution in Iraq both of the complex are
tied in with each other unsurprisingly
Washington is divided on the best
approach to stop Isis the White House
defends its current strategy are we
going to
light our hair on fire every time that
there is a setback in the campaign
against ISIL but some lawmakers continue
to hammer away at Obama's approach
Republican Senator John McCain who
supported the Iraq war wants US troops
back on the ground we need to have a
robust strategy we need more troops on
the ground we need for air controllers
we're just referring to air strikes so
what do you think is it the USS job to
ensure Isis is eliminated in Iraq and if
so is it using the best strategy
[Music]